en marzo luján lucía como un desierto de
cemento consecuencia de una durísima
cuarentena en china en febrero un mes
antes esta ciudad daba nombre a una
neumonía que por entonces afectaba sobre
todo a asia se la rebautizó como covite
19 y para el 11 de marzo ya era una
pandemia el anuncio lo hizo la
organización mundial de la salud en una
sala que no conocía por ese entonces el
aislamiento social de hable hecho más
accesibles al lado ms ha estado
evaluando este brote durante todo el día
y estamos profundamente preocupados
tanto por los niveles alarmantes de
propagación y gravedad como por los
niveles alarmantes de inacción hoy día
lar ming levels of in action
we have performer y por lo tanto hemos
evaluado que el coi 19 se puede
caracterizar como una pandemia
cuando el kobe 19 se convirtió en
pandemia un indicador sobre el nivel de
propagación del virus que desde ese
momento comenzó una escalada
internacional había poco más de 100.000
casos y 4200 muertos tras la
declaratoria del 11 de marzo el 4 de
abril el mundo supera el millón de
contagios europa es el nuevo epicentro
el 11 de abril eeuu supera los 20.000
muertos y sobrepasa a italia como el
país con más fallecidos en el mundo los
contagios globales son 1.600.000 y los
decesos se acercan a los 100.000 para el
13 de julio latinoamérica superó por
primera vez a norteamérica en la cifra
de muertos la región era el nuevo
epicentro casos 12 7 millones y muertos
566.000 en el planeta el 7 de septiembre
index se convirtió en la segunda nación
con más contagios por encima de brasil y
sólo por detrás de eeuu los contagios
eran más de 27 millones y los muertos
876.000 en ese entonces
este viernes in the registró un nuevo
récord diario con más de 96 mil casos
ningún otro país del mundo tiene ahora
mismo un ritmo de contagios tan alto
como esta nación